o wissen sie mein problem ist ich kenne
ja die fakten ich weiß dass sich die
erde im letzten jahrhundert stark
erwärmt hat ich weiß dass 97 prozent der
wissenschaftler decken das ist auf uns
menschen zurückzuführen und ich weiß
dass jeder einzelne von uns die
verantwortung für den klimawandel
mitträgt und trotzdem kriege ich nicht
hin irgendwas zu machen ich es wieder
mehr fleisch war sinnlos im auto herum
letzte woche sah sich mal wieder in
einem innerdeutschen flug ich habe auch
ein schlechtes gewissen aber ich finde
einfach keine motivation niemandem fällt
der klimawandel reicht wissen und
rationalität sind eine gute basis aber
bringen in der regel keine persönliche
motivation was sie brauchen ist ein
starker emotionaler trigger ich bin aber
ein sehr rationaler mensch jeder mensch
ist anständig für emotionale trigger man
muss nur den richtigen finden
wir finden die tiere was löst bei ihnen
der eisbär aus heißt er ist jetzt auch
schon so ein bisschen ausgeruht sie
befolgen auf instagram derzeit fünf
verschiedene kann sie nichts anderes
posten als tier bilder und videos ich
glaube wir sind hier auf einer guten
spur wussten sie zum beispiel dass
meeresschildkröten ebenfalls vom
klimawandel bedroht sind das geschlecht
der schildkröten babys wird maßgeblich
von der temperatur während der brutzeit
bestimmt an warmen stränden schlüpfen
meerweibchen an kälteren stränden
schlüpften mehr männchen mit der
erderwärmung zu holen die menschen aus
zu stehen und damit die ganze art das
wusste ich nicht kann sich mal diese
bibel schild gründe und sie wurde gute
start aber wir kommen dem noch näher
wie finden sie das jedermann kann dass
die wissen dass man als vom aussterben
bedroht sind
aber wussten sie dass der klimawandel
eine zusätzliche bedrohung darstellt
wegen des bambus recht neue studie in
nature climate change viele war muss
arten ernähren sich gerade mal alle 10
bis 120 jahre und können des
nicht so leicht auf stelle
klimaveränderungen reagieren damit ist
die fast einzige nahrungsquelle der
pandas bedroht das ist wirklich
interessant wie finden sie die nagetiere
ja die lieben nagetiere kennen sie zwei
phasen zwei phasen sind meine
lieblingstiere was ist mit demut wissen
sie zwei phasen leben eben im gebirge
ich weiß du kurz in kühlen höhen selten
unter 2.500 höhenmetern da sie recht
hitzeempfindlich sind der klimawandel
zwingt sie immer weiter nach oben
auszuweichen
das irgendwann geht ihnen schlichtweg
der lebensraum aus kennen sie dieses
video wollen nämlich verarschen das ist
eines meiner lieblings video sie sollten
es sich noch mal ansehen
ich kann das jetzt nicht ich muss was
tun
ich muss was tun dankeschön
bitteschön
[Musik]
nein nein nein